[Musik]
hey leute heute gibt es ein neues
grundrezept nämlich in meiner buck
schule so nenne ich jetzt einfach mal
denn wir machen heute die swiss mehring
buttercreme und ich finde die mal super
geeignet wenn man was festes spritzen
möchte wie zum beispiel rosen mit einer
tülle oder den voll kleingeld machen
möchte deshalb ich nämlich vor dass ist
ja dieser neue trend
das zeige ich euch aber auch noch ganz
in ruhe und für die buttercreme
benötigen wir erstmal drei grundzutaten
und dann aromatisieren wir noch ich
starte jetzt in diesen drei grundzutaten
und das ist einmal weiß das müsst ihr
ganz sauber trennen das ist ganz wichtig
dann habe ich ihr zimmer warme butter
die darf auch nicht zu weich sein und
zucker und ich zeige euch jetzt direkt
die zubereitung und er dürfte sich
abgeschreckt sein denn wir verwenden
zwar weiß aber so wirklich froh ist es
nicht mehr weil wir das jetzt über dem
wasserbad bearbeiten das heißt es gibt
keine salmonellen gefahr und
grundsätzlich solltet ihr immer frische
eier bio eiern in freilandhaltung also
achtet da sowieso grundsätzlich auch so
ein paar sachen wenn ihr euer kauft und
das gebe ich jetzt wie gesagt hier auch
mein wasserbad wichtig ist dass euer
wasser nicht die schüsse das heißt
wasser im topf nicht ganz voll machen
einmal aufkochen und dann das ganze auf
mittlerer stufe c acht minuten lang
richtig schön erhitzen und dabei gibt ja
auch schon in zucker mit hinzu und merkt
dass sich die zuckerkristalle in den
acht minuten so ein bisschen auflösen
und du musst doch dabei ständig rühren
damit er ihnen keine ruhe kommt
[Musik]
so über einem wasserbad haben sich jetzt
die zuckerkristalle im besten falle
aufgelöst das könnt ihr auch
kontrollieren indem ihr die jetzt sehr
dünn flüssige masse einmal zwischen die
sauberen fingern nimmt und dann spürt
ihr einfach kein zucker korn und das
kommt jetzt in die saubere rührschüssel
ich empfehle in diesem fall wirklich
eine küchenmaschine weil wir das ganze
jetzt wirklich sehr lange schlangen
müssen also die masse lassen wird
abkühlen das dauert so ungefähr 20
minuten und dann schlagen wir sie auf
höchster stufe mit dem schneebesen
aufsatz mindestens zehn minuten sogar
richtig schön glänzenden baiser masse so
nach zehn minuten haben wir ein richtig
schöne glänzende baiser masse und dies
auch sehr fest aber es fehlt ja nur noch
die butter und an der stelle einmal den
aufsatz wechsel ich gebe jetzt nur noch
die besseren wir wollten nichts
verschwenden und dann nehme ich den röhr
haken aufsatz und gäbe dann nach und
nach die butter hinzu und an der stelle
ist es wichtig dass er das ganze noch
mal 15 minuten richtig schön aufstieg
denn muss sich vorstellen die länge er
die mutter schlägt umso schöner und
cremiger und leckerer wird sie einfach
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich der mutter auch noch mal
richtig viel zeit gegeben also 15
minuten solltet ihr das ganze ruhig auf
mittlerer stufe schlagen lassen bei der
bast natürlich die höchste stufe also
richtig schön aufschlagen und bei der
butter gerne in die mittlere stufe
nehmen und dann dürft ihr euch auch
nicht vorstellen dass ihr da auch butter
bei eis oder das sehr gut riecht
schmeckt meine mutter verändert total
seinen geschmack wenn man das richtig
schön herr cremig schlägt und jetzt
kommt ja auch noch was dazu nämlich zum
aromatisieren irgendeine zutat die ihr
jetzt gerne mit entweder lemon gehört
das rezept dazu habe ich euch abgefilmt
das passt er perfekt in ihr habt ja so
viele eigelbe übrig und da kann man
einfach wunderbar lemon curt raus
zaubern oder zum beispiel marmelade
irgendeine die gerne mit da könnt ihr
auch zum beispiel kaffeepulver
kakaopulver nehmen und und was ich heute
mache ist vanille extrakt dann habe ich
eine vanille buttercreme die passt zu
vielen toten und meine torte die ich
vorhabe dazu passt dass nämlich auch
sehr gut also da gebe ich jetzt noch
ordentlich was rhein-ruhr das nochmal
gut um und dann ist die buttercreme
fertig zur haltbarkeit ganz kurz also
auf zimmertemperatur könnt ihr das ganze
drei tage lagern das ist gar kein
problem im kühlschrank sogar bis zu zwei
bis drei wochen dann müsste einfach mal
selber abschmecken und das ganze könnt
ihr auch ein ich werde euch habe alle
genauen infos in die video beschreibung
reinschreiben genauso wie die
mengenangaben also schaut er auf jeden
fall rein
[Musik]
so das ist jetzt die fertige buttercreme
richtig schön mit vanille aromatisiert
und damit könnt ihr jetzt von dann
torten einkleiden also es ist ein super
untergrund für fondant außerdem könnt
ihr blumen spritzen rosetten mit
verschiedenen tönen blüten alles was ihr
möchtet oder und das mache ich ihr könnt
den voll kleingeld zauber und nein nicht
fort leitwort kleinkrieg und das mache
ich also das zauber ich jetzt aus der
creme freue ich mich schon sehr darauf
dass wir dann extra video hoffe ich
natürlich dass sie fleißig einschaltet
außerdem solltet ihr diesem video im
dörfchen nach oben da lassen wir mehr
von cookies buck schule sehen möchtet
bestes rezept einfach erklärt und da
will ich mal sagen bis zum nächsten lauf
des kitsches können
[Musik]